[Music]
Warner Brothers a new line neatly get
their logos out of the way in 23 tiny
seconds only we're not done with a logo
drain cuz our has yet to check in after
everything we've seen disembodied will
be talking want to make the events of
your movie seem like they're based on a
true story dig up the Warrens connection
to the Amityville Horror a story that
has been questioned about its
authenticity for decades discount Joseph
gordon-levitt okay we ready then let's
get started
character at a movie at 1:39 marks is
what I said at the zero zero zero mark
envision yourself in a halo of glowing
white lies it will protect you don't cut
scare I mean try not laughing during
this awful it's impossible movie proves
beer Farmiga has a way better imaginary
dream shotgun than you do by the way
this movie emulates the first Amityville
Horror in that the people sleeping
during all the shooting are the deepest
sleepiness motherfuckers in the world
you slow this down you can literally
spot a dozen different ways this mirror
shot is off what an asshole creepy ghost
kid laughing creepily in a horror movie
cliche also what an asshole Jesus Christ
this is a vision right she can't even
keep up with a creeper kid and a vision
how's she gonna possibly hold her own
when this goes real life oh she's not
oculus again ah Kim Basinger I'm kind of
confused if fluorine gets strangled here
does she die in the matrix also somehow
even though I thought she was walking
through a previous murder from the past
this chick is still strangled by a white
face zombie none ghost born out of a
mirror and when you put it all in
writing yes it does seem pretty goddamn
ridiculous with stacks chairs like this
what kind of Jenga bolt is going on with
this furniture the people around the
table should not be buying this but that
halo of glowing light is probably
preventing them from being skeptical
this is close to hell as a everyone
again the end the end reading
[Music]
Jesus Christ movie we get it we're in
London the song alone was overkill but
the British Invasion seizure was dead
horse beating levels of unnecessary
right Phalke get just a wanker the
audience look at this movie is going to
speak another language without giving me
any subtitles I might as well give up
can't just go into another country like
this and expect me to follow along with
my rudimentary understanding of whatever
language this is I feel like maybe this
movie isn't British enough this is a
nifty little shot here where we pan up
with mom into the hall window and threw
it into the bedroom then follow the
daughter back out into the hall my only
issue is that nothing in the story or
script of this movie comes close to
matching the creativity displayed here
in this shop the shot is above this
movie actually for being such a well
shot will be overall when we move us it
look it's bad enough we're conjuring The
Amityville Horror do we need two
conjuring to a discount Ouija board into
this thing
look if this movie's gonna go all
insidious on me why not just call this
insidious for you already got Patrick
Wilson so I'm already having a hard time
distinguishing this movie from those
movies this kind of pounding would
definitely make me jump out of bed and
fear for my life but this girl don't
give up if a movie opens with excessive
evidence the family is poor you can bank
on even more evidence piling up as you
go forward also a sweet spontaneous wet
t-shirt contest I'm genetically
hardwired by logic to laugh out loud
whenever I hear the phrase ghost hunter
regardless of context and now we're
gonna talk to my next guest dr. Steven
Kaplan who says that the investigations
the Warrens conducted into the
Amityville haunting is a load of hogwash
then why isn't he the hero of the story
careful who you call a liar what are you
gonna do about it
fraud fight first night bang some doors
second night move a single swing it's
gonna be 17 or 1890 where these ghosts
do any real damage isn't it what are you
doing you playing a game with Billy
you're both here talking to her and
playing a game with Billy can wait you
bored demons man how do they work
did she get over there that fast without
making any noise ah hutch this goes on
for some time
like most ghosts from the fiery depths
of hell this guy likes to play with
children's toys
okay the kid turned it off and kicked it
into the tent now it's in his bedroom
and turned back on I might be weirded
out too but remember this is the 70s in
the 80s I had electronic toys doing
weird kid all the time America didn't
really master the glitch free
battery-powered toy until Teddy Ruxpin
so this kid should at least be
considering the totally plausible
explanation of toy malfunction does this
movie know how sick sense it is right
now I don't think it does because if it
did someone would have said something
and this scene wouldn't be so sick since
right now audio-based jump-scare cue
movie check your D B's on it because I'm
thinking about suing your ass that was
loud also okay fine that was scary
unexpected and loud I felt like I was
gonna die but it's up with this dude if
you want them out of the house show up
and scare Francis O'Connor
no one believes kids unless they're in
the crucible those two really really
wants these people out of his house
decides to retire when the adult shows
up super poor family has giant house
with a television that has a goddamn
remote control in 1977
it's like dad spent all the money just
hours before he skipped out on his
family that's the only reason I can
think of that they're so poor because
earlier mom said she had no money for
biscuits and even though she has twice
since produced magic biscuits she still
hasn't sold this fucking luxury TV and
forced her kids to seek entertainment in
their own imaginations every single
exterior establishing shot of this house
opens with a car zooming by everyone not
to mention the fact that we already were
just inside the house let's see we've
got Queen Elizabeth family have a
stuttering British kid so this movie is
basically the King's Speech when it
comes down to it Direct TV just reading
book dude I don't watch her you're
really enjoying that market doctor
speech anyway be honest
okay but why spend so many days pounding
on doors and rolling fire trucks around
if you have this serious appointment
also why does he give up after that why
not appear behind here five six seven
more times until she leaves hi Mona Lisa
on Mac yeah I know I know the castle but
I didn't think it was that bad
this guy knows his wife like I know his
wife wink wink nudge nudge say no more
anyway he should know that her
disturbance has nothing to do with his
shoe painting but what's in the painting
you can still do the lectures no new
cases and by that I mean we will take a
new case ten minutes from now also
you're not gonna tell your husband that
the nun he painted is the exact same
done that strangled you with a Lutz
house but why because if it's a TV shows
another scary ghost and holy SH they
talk to it okay okay first of all what
if you sleep untie this middle school
now second of all why you acting like
you didn't literally see a remote
control moving old man ghosts earlier
today did you tell anyone about that you
think he's impervious to knots
once again they super loud pounding on
the store not only doesn't wake the
entire house it doesn't even wake the
sleeping sister in this room Janet knows
this house is haunted but decides to
walk through it in the dark anyway
there's been a couple decent scares in
this movie but now it resorts to the
pulling the covers off and yelling
technique you two being with this god
damn it are you going to forget the bite
on your daughter's shoulder and I'll ask
again
does this go scaring the kids and not
the adult for is it bad that I didn't
realize there were two brothers until
just now can you imagine what a good
scare that would have been if there
wasn't two brothers instead movies been
so negligent with I think the taller one
I had no idea until I rewound this movie
and found this kid a couple other times
playing in significant background filler
finally bring me a check from the
kitchen would it be great if he went to
get the chair and when he came back his
partner was murdered
haha maybe I should make horror movies
no lice maybe this King idiot hears
Thunder rumbling in the house and then
suggests mice and fires this difficult
on the spot of the cop this dick had
finally figured out if you need people
to leave your house you do in front of
the authorities exterior shot suggest
we're back in America for now but the
lack of rapid montage involving u.s.
monuments over Jimi Hendrix's
instrumental national anthem I can't be
sure
Lorraine is transfixed by her daughter
who's obviously transfixed towards
something down the hall but this is a
horror movie and Lorraine won't notice
the demon nun until after her daughter
points it out after god knows how many
years being thwarted by them the ghosts
have finally decided to haunt at the
source of their enemies you ruined our
haunting now you must pay the price of
slam doors in
thuds in the night yeah we all know
where this is going right this goes to
understand symmetry Oh
laureen's been in the further this whole
time I got a question though
how did her daughter show up in her
vision you telling me her vision has no
rules okay I don't like that so what's
stopping you also why even tell her
these visions raise more questions than
answers
TV crew captures haunting on film but I
guess the late 70s viewing audience
collectively cried Photoshop or
something mom looks concerned about her
daughter's health but Carrie on TV
interview why is the sister still
looking at her obviously possessed
younger sibling like she's telling a
story about girl scouts
why isn't older sister freaking the f
out I'm sure the haunting is plenty hot
news in this community but no bread that
should get the entire front page by
itself and certainly top of the fold
placement over some soccer controversy
it won't help
really but isn't it about time they took
this tent down it's kind of a catalyst
for all bullshit boat isn't it this
isn't creepy anymore you did this like
in the first 20 minutes and you've moved
on to possessing small children when I
go back to random toy degree is it just
a pad to the runtime if this dude shows
up as a guy carrying an umbrella all of
a sudden I'm officially done with this
movie if you can do this as a ghost you
can literally do anything it should have
won already based on the true story also
yeah I mean now we're talking about
transforming yourself into whatever
drawing is on a child's tour and this
isn't your house kind of a dick ghost
haunts the neighbor's house oh yeah it
was Janet all along wait what
this dude could clearly kill everyone
here and not even think about it but he
fails miserably and he basically just
causes damage and cleanup headaches and
there is a family in London that
desperately needs our help can you
believe this movie is at the hour mark
and the Warrens aren't in London yet
this thing is over two hours I had a
premonition of your death moulding
stalagmites come on we don't run from
fights this works I understand that
Janet is levitated did that happen in
here as well yeah more than once when
did that happen did we miss the
levitation are we talking about the time
when she fell in a bit fifty Christ
compels you
my ex-husband bought all the furniture
with the house when we moved in this
family unlike most horror families has
actually lived in this house for a while
now why did it take so long for this
goes to get pissed off and Oh believe me
it can hurt you but it's not going to
right now or anything he also told me he
can stop smoking any time he wants he
just doesn't want it demon makes them
all turn their backs because he's
suddenly shine there's no good reason
except to have a unique perspective on
this demon interview scene let's go
down a business what are you saying
you're telling me no one has snuck a
peek yet you see this 50 crosses
upstairs don't deter this dude but this
one tiny cross does are you sensing a
presence no it's just the opposite I'm
not sensing anything all right how can
that be we could be looking at
hysterical neurosis that would explain
the multiple personalities no it
wouldn't she wouldn't do that
it helps me sleep Lisa no I'm not going
anywhere that's not what we saw earlier
you fell out of bed remember I'm sorry I
didn't believe say what you will these
hauntings appear to be good for
mother-daughter relationships
oh she's being haunted by st. Peter this
asshole needed a distraction in order to
scare the audience I mean Genet these
two must sleep like the dead how much
noise did they just sleep through here
like three minutes of solid petrified
screaming silly this dude's plan was to
suffocate her with curtains goddamn man
you just pulled her through the ceiling
into this room he transformed herself
into an illustration okay you just
killed something using your own powers
they're gonna believe her right
since this room was padlocked from the
outside and this girl was found
screaming and suffocating inside the
only other explanation is that the mom
did all this without the warrants down
the hall hearing anything and what about
the claims that Jenna has been
teleporting around the house in her
sleep you mean like last night when you
found her in the locked room what the
actual Jesus she teleported herself into
a room locked from the outside
easy discount gene Shalit I've already
covered this but good job copying me
she's gotta spit it out taken another
set before you turn back uh-huh I saw
the demon wants the humans to down his
existence what a weird-ass ghost man
he's literally just playing with them so
you really do believe them
yes we do Lorraine made and promised
before they came here that they believed
at the first sign of this haunting being
real yet here they are twelve hours in
at least could five pieces of true
haunting evidence yet neither has even
brought up the we should leave packed no
one would be seated during the Patrick
Wilson Elvis karaoke scene the fact that
this random leaning against the wall
generally unused guitar is in perfect
tune a Texan and a half to anyone that
ever played a guitar in real life though
for scorekeeping reasons well rounded up
to two it's so small and light har-har
did you ever worry that there might be
something hiding under your bed at night
yep he's actually fixing their plumbing
while staying there as a ghost hunter
because Hollywood only knows one gear
when it comes to super good characters
and that's all the way baby look I'm
fine with the Warrens integrating
themselves into this family trying to
get them to think happy thoughts and all
that this movie waste so much time
this basement was absolutely constructed
with the specific goal of adding to the
tension of a horror film
I mean who builds that many half walls
with that many open board slots yeah
it's scary I just don't know why this
motherfucker has to creep anywhere he
could just transport himself over to Ed
and grab him right now if you wanted
haha I was gonna kill that but now I've
decided to kill you instead haha I'm so
great
she clearly got bit in this water but
he's casually feeling around like
there's a definite nearby plug drain or
a million-dollar heart of the sea
diamond down there he's back from the
grave because his business has
unfinished teeth even though this chair
is definitely evil and connected to the
ghost these assholes still put all the
Christmas tree decorations on it causing
Janet PTSD every trip back for a new
ornament
oh it's the brother she just teleported
into the next jump scare the producers
of this movie really hate chairs locked
doors are no match for Ed's average
human man strength I think there's
something wrong with your wiring movie
doesn't even try to show you how he
untangled her from all that mess this
video is offered as proof of Janet
faking it but if she's being possessed
as they've seen happen doesn't this
video basically prove nothing also does
anyone remember that a hall chair got
thrown on a line from the kitchen to the
living room and is this footage from
five minutes ago because so much more
happened during that scene plus her
brother was there and there was no
footage of how she got into that
impossible closet either a war the part
where she magically appeared in that
room or the bite marks which everyone
conveniently forgets
[Music]
movie offers a the old-timey cover of
the wallflower song from Zoolander is
this movie seriously about to turn on
him seeing a spilled tape in the shape
of a cross really x marks the spot come
on I can see that this is clever but why
would he leave out specific words two
different times that when combined
magically form one message what kind of
convenient ghost affliction causes this
oh now you'll feel the presence you mean
this whole thing was a ruse to get the
Warrens out here so that this demon non
could kill it geez never considered
working in America she survives this
thunder and lightning storm during the
climax get out of here the site is being
blocked by the inhuman spirit it's just
unfortunate that her site which detects
inhuman spirits was blocked by an
inhuman spirit that's annoying the
demon's name gives us power over and we
can cast it out yeah really okay
whatever I'm up for whatever at this
point I mean Denzel could start
narrating is one of these characters and
this could be a huge fallen prequel at
this point I wouldn't carry your name
you didn't ask for it it was given this
is the fastest solvable riddle since bat
killer in Batman Forever no ed use your
god-given door breaking hands demon that
went through all the trouble of throwing
a couch in front of a window a minute
ago somehow can't stop it from breaking
through a floor steam burns at Warren
giving him conveniently blurry vision
for the last several minutes of this
over bloom bolt Edie is clearly
oblivious to the Red Power Ranger
stalking him from behind I'm kind of
impressed by the new Power Rangers
reboots marketing department here so
I'll let it slide yeah no I won't and
some people said it would take 600 years
to cut through this door with a tiny axe
old Andy did it in less than 20 find the
hell with a demon teller its name
considering the power uname possesses in
this world well no you've stamped your
Bible a bunch before your daughter snap
you out of it
I need my Bible I brought the exact one
that Ida faced an earlier scene I
figured who buys a new Bible
those are the exact letters on a
bookcase from earlier you mean they just
happen to decorate their bookshelves
with the five letters of the demon
they're chasing or did the demon do this
because it really wants to tell her its
name for some reason do they have other
letters strewn about the house or just
these five and they just happen to buy
two a's and all this bloody hell
Valek if the demon is this powerful
maybe we should just let it win well you
know what to do now
go get that dudes week door chopping axe
and chop this down don't leave anything
to chance
lion ghost hunter is every bit as
distracted by a sudden homely zoetrope
as the little boy was earlier and I may
never have written a more ridiculous
sentence one day I'm gonna have to ask
people who make horror movies why a
demon with Duty making more work for
yourself asshole let me go in alright
while I go in here will you go upstairs
and cut down that elder blade that form
from the lightning hitting that tree
thanks I owe you one
this demon don't give a fuck about
Loraine coming into the house yeah that
would have taken him down with her
boobies continue to perpetuate the line
well what are you waiting for say it's
name get the demon is as strong why is
there any tension in this cookie movies
climax thanks for that by the way okay
now it's double the bull like three
times as much double the bullet still
doesn't prove to the church there's a
demon here though
yeah but how they didn't never have
proof then Laureen sent the demon back
to hell so what else could people find
after this was over this tape which
couldn't be manipulated at all is going
to prove everything this very movie said
it couldn't anyway
I got the flow you all got to go so go
get your bags so we can go house on the
ceiling
feminine pizza bag and minimizing job
loss why would you think that of me no I
am the one who knocks it's coming from
inside the walls
[Music]
okay have I done my job up to your
goddamn standards because according to
my standards
you fit the model of drug-seeking
behavior now you may have a thick skin a
skin stole our biscuits those are
cookies cookies are cookies and biscuits
I'm pissed if you call cookies biscuits
- what do you call biscuits so I'm not
saying scones you're up early
yeah I couldn't sleep get inspired
[Music]
Oh first I'll just reach in and pull my
legs out
no I'll pull my arms out which might be
daddy's gonna kill Ralphie no he's not
no